another issue that dak prescott's been
involved in and he got some
ridiculous blow back from someone in the
media a couple of weeks ago he got some
support from hayden hurst when the
falcons and the dolphins
played over the weekend or the falcons
and the cowboys excuse me
uh dak prescott and the issue of mental
health aaron rodgers earlier this week
speaking to reporters addressing the
important issue of mental health here's
aaron rodgers
i think there's been a lot of players
across the sporting leagues who
spoke out you know i know that kevin
love
said some things a few years ago and at
the time i remember
some of the responses to it there's
there's a weird uh
stigma around it that's almost weakness
to either ask for help or to
admit you're struggling with things or
admit uh you know
thoughts you might have the negative
thoughts about yourself
um i think uh this strength
is taking care of yourself and taking
care of your mind and understanding how
important your thoughts are because they
become things
and understanding uh how important
positivity is and your attitude and
waking up uh each day with the right
focus and the right mindset and taking
time to be quiet during your day and
whether it's five minutes ten minutes an
hour you know and still your mind
allow your your brain to rewire itself
and and change uh you know change the
outlook and of the cells in your body
get them to get out of protection mode
and into growth mode
um i think it's it's great you know when
i saw what dak said i plot him i think
is phenomenal speaking out
because that's true courage and that's
true strength it's not a weakness at all
it's not
you know and anybody who attacks it uh
you know it has other people's opinions
of ourselves have really nothing to do
with us
that's a great line i heard um and other
people's opinions of dak
has nothing to do with them because of
their own insecurities but
their inability to deal with their own
[ __ ] probably
and i applaud i applaud dak and
and i think uh hurst as well had some
words for him after the game i think
it's a beautiful thing when people start
talking about it
because i think at the at the bare
minimum it makes you more relatable to
people
that you know we have the same struggles
and the same issues and the same desires
to grow and change and see things in a
better positive light
that so many people out there do and i
think the more that we can connect with
people
especially on conversations like this
you're talking about matt i think
uh the better our society can can be
moving forward as a connected
society built around love and positivity
another sound bite that a few years ago
i never would have dreamed that we'd
hear in that context
in that sense right right but thank god
for it peter
thank god for it the brain is as
imperfect an organ
as every other organ in the body can be
you break your arm
you need an appendectomy right you get
cancer whatever the case may be
mental health and and uh and issues
of that that type it's it's incredibly
common
and the worst thing you can do when
you're dealing with those issues is to
ignore them
to to have that mindset well there is a
stigma
and i'm not going to be perceived as
tough if i
if i say i need to talk to somebody or
that i can't handle things it's okay to
not be able to handle things
and when you think about what a
professional athlete has to handle my
goodness especially early 20s
right you've got money that you've never
had before what the hell do i do with it
it's stressful to have to figure out
what the hell do i do with this where do
i get a bank account who do i trust
to invest and who's going to try to
steal it from me and then you've got
people who want it from you who expect
things who are going to accuse you of
changing you're different you've changed
if you don't give them what they want
and then you got to go perform you got
to step out into a crucible with 70
000 people who hate you and are
screaming negative things at you and
then you go to social media
and god forbid you don't give somebody
two touchdowns and a hundred yards
rushing
that weekend for their fantasy team or
they're gonna make threats at you i mean
that you know we we think it's this life
of luxury
it's not and and that doesn't even get
to the physical toll
of playing football i mean when you
think of what these
guys go through at an early age where
their brains haven't even fully
developed yet they're not fully
developed at least until they're 25.
we're putting a lot of stuff on these
guys and we just think oh they're rich
and they're famous what are they
complaining about well there's a lot of
issues that come from this and the
average person
would not even be able to handle five
percent of it peter
yeah i think one of the biggest things
that that teams
increasingly in the last few years have
really tried to address is
the the money that's given to players
at a very early age and uh
because clearly if you go from let's say
you're in college football and
look i don't i don't know how college
football works in terms of
you know who gets paid who doesn't who
i i i truly don't know
and i would assume that there are some
guys who come out of college
and come into the nfl who would not have
been able to buy
more than a happy meal at mcdonald's you
know in their college days and now all
of a sudden they find that they've got
two million dollars
in their checking account or whatever
account it is
that is the thing that over the years i
know that so many nfl teams
have tried to address and they should
address not to mention
the incredible mental pressure
that there is all of a sudden you're
going from playing a game in college
for no money you get nothing whether you
win you get nothing if you lose
whatever and now you know you understand
that
your livelihood is on the line every
week imagine the mental pressure
that is on that and again nobody's
crying for these guys
uh you know it's a great life for so
many of them but
that doesn't take away the fact that
there is some pressure
there's definitely pressure there's that
ever present possibility of a serious
injury
something that would take away your
career like that and then you know
you know you've got a limited number of
years you know that
as you get farther and farther into your
career which is just a matter of two
or three or four years that's when you
start after worrying about
am i making too much money are they
going to draft somebody that's going to
take my place how long can i hold on
and then you have to pick up and move to
another city because you get cut by the
team that you really wanted to play for
it's one of the unintended consequences
of free agency
and the salary cap guys wanted to be
able to go wherever they want well some
guys want to stay where they are for the
entirety of their careers and they get
dumped two weeks before the start of the
season good luck
you're done now you got to go funds you
got to move across the country to find
employment so
it's there there is a ton of stress
for all professional athletes and
there's a ton of stress
especially in this day and age with
everything that's going on in the world
we all
experience it if you need help you
get help and you don't worry about
getting
you know a a weird look or a weird
passive-aggressive comment from a friend
or a family member and those people who
would do that
are the ones who really do need the help
they need to understand
that not everyone can deal with the
pressures of
of modern life especially as modern life
continues to get stranger and stranger
peter
mike you know the other day i had a
conversation with dak prescott after
that weird game where they came back to
beat atlanta
40 to 39 and at the end of the economy
he was driving home
and at the end of the conversation i
said hey dak i'm going to tell you one
thing
i said i got i can't imagine how you
felt about your life
you know this off season you know where
every 15 minutes there is a new story
about your contract and four years five
years this amount that amount franchise
tag not franchise tag
i said i got so sick of it i wrote my
column one week i said that's it
i mean i am i am going rogue
i'm not discussing one sentence of dak
prescott's contract
until it's resolved you know and he goes
thank you thank you he said i i
sometimes i think sometimes well hey i'm
just young i don't understand and
and i haven't seen everything in the
past i said no no no no no
this was the all-time contract
discussion
record and he just started laughing and
he goes hey listen
it's like i tell the beat guys and and
beat women
uh he said i i i said at one point i
said look
there's a reason why i have an agent he
handles everything
i don't talk about this stuff so please
don't ask me about it
and you know i got the feeling that
along with everything else and obviously
you know his his brother's death this
off season
everything going on in his life uh
you know it was a pretty crazy year for
dak prescott
well let me tell you on top of
everything else i respect dak prescott
for one of the things i
respect him for the most his ability
to to never cave in to that
that schtick that jerry jones throw your
arm around the guy's shoulder and
explain to him why the team needs him to
take this deal and
he's never given in he's always stood
firm
we rarely see a football player do that
at some point they give in at some point
they sign on the dotted line
they feel like they have to because it's
it's for the good of the
team and you're being selfish if you try
to get more and
and that i i i i'm blown away
of all teams to be able to take that
stand against
the dallas cowboys where there's a
proven track record of
ownership getting involved to get the
deal done
to be the closer and it always works
except when it doesn't and it didn't
work and hasn't worked so far on dac
well here's the to me mike this is the
most interesting thing
and i absolutely ripped the cowboys and
jerry and stephen jones who
look they run their team their own way
and and they've won three super bowls so
you know i'm not sitting here saying i
know any more than they do
i really am not but they blew it with
dak prescott in a very
very big way and it's getting worse now
okay
and and you say why is it getting worse
well they blew it because contracts for
quarterbacks
never go down never never never they
never will
so to not sign them a year and a half
ago
was an idiotic thing to not throw
another couple million or not throw
another year on the thing
you've been around dak prescott a lot
you know i mean just
give him the amount of years he wants
he's going to be the most responsible
human being in your organization there's
jason witten
he's gone now there's dak prescott those
are the guys
but the other part of it mike is that
it's very likely
that in the next two years at least next
year
the salary cap goes down 23 million
dollars
to 175 million and it's likely that in
2022
it's way down so you're talking about
quarterback money keeps going like this
and
the salary cap is going to go down 13
next year and so you know the cowboys
really are in a hole with this
and the bottom line both figuratively
and literally here is 37.68 million
dollars
that's what dak is entitled to next year
if the cowboys apply the tag again
regardless of where the cap goes
so if the cap goes down 13 his pay goes
up
20 37.68 in cash and cap space
with no ability to to wave a magic wand
and shrink the cap figure no not unless
you sign into a long-term deal
and that's what he's going to be dealing
with next year same as this share and
it's a very simple analysis
i get 37.68 million this year and who
the hell knows what's going to happen in
2022 maybe i become a free agent
what are you gonna offer me on a
long-term deal to get me to give that up
so
he's winning on the field he's winning
off the field when it relates to how
much the cowboys are ultimately gonna
have to pay him and he's definitely
winning when it comes to
making us all aware of the realities of
mental health so good for dak on all
fronts we look forward to seeing him
play this weekend